the goal for the next few lectures is to
prove Freeman's theorem which we
discussed last time so we started with
this tool that we proved called the
political Russia inequality which tells
us that if you have a set a now in an
arbitrary abelian group and if a has
controlled doubling it has bounded
doubling then all the further iterated
some sets have banded growth as well so
this is what we proved last time okay so
we're going to be using the plant
kirusha inequality many times but
there's some other tools I need to tell
you about so the next tool is no mess
rules are covering lemma so let me first
give you the statement and then I'll
explain some intuition
I think the technique is more important
than the statement but in any case
here's what it says if you have X and B
there are subsets of some arbitrary
abelian group if you have the inequality
that X plus B is at most K times the
size of P so the size of X plus P is at
most K times the size of B then there
exists some subset T of X with the size
of T being at most K such that X is
contained in T plus B minus B
okay so that's the statement of Lucia
covering them up so let me try to
explain what it is about so the idea
here is that if you're in a situation
where if it looks like so you should
think of B as a ball right so if it
looks like X plus B might be coverable
by K translates of B so here supposed to
think of be like a ball in in a metric
space then X is actually coverable so if
it looks like meaning just by size alone
a size info alone so just based on the
size if it looks like X plus B might be
coverable by K different translator P
then actually acts as coverable but you
have to use slightly larger balls by K
copies of B minus B so you should think
of B minus B as slightly larger balls
than be yourself right so if B were an
actual ball in Euclidean space and B
minus B is the same ball with twice the
radius
[Applause]
looser covering mama is a really
important tool the proof is not very
long and it's important to understand
the idea of this proof right so this is
a proof not just the additive
combinatorics but something that happens
it's a standard idea in analysis this is
very important to understand this idea
and the key idea here I think the proof
is more important than a statement up
there the key idea here is that if you
want to produce a covering one way to
produce a covering is to take a maximal
packing a maximal packing using with
balls
for instance implies a covering with
balls twice as large ok so let me
illustrate out with the picture suppose
you have some space that I want to cover
but you get to use let's say you need
balls so how can I make sure I can cover
the space you see unit balls and I don't
want to use too many unit balls so what
you can do is let me start by a maximal
cut a maximal set of unit balls so with
centers so it's not half unit balls so
the radius is one half
okay so I put in as many as I can so
that I cannot pudding anymore so that's
what Maximo means mou here
doesn't mean the maximum number although
if you put in the maximum number that's
also okay but Maximo means that I just
cannot putting any more balls that are
not overlapping then if I have this
configuration now what I do is I double
the radii of all the balls okay so
whoever takes today's knows will have a
fun time drawing this picture so this
has to be a covering of the original
space because if you had missed some
point I could have put it blue ball in
yes because one of the space has some
narrow portion it doesn't matter if you
formulate this correctly so if you miss
if you miss some point so here so it
depends on how you formulate this
discovering so the point is that if you
take a maximal set of points when you
expand you have to cover the whole space
because if you missed some point right
so imagine if you had for example if
suppose you miss okay okay suppose you
had missed some point over here then I
could have put an extra ball him so if
you had missed some point over here that
means that I should have being able to
put into putting that ball there
initially so this is it's a very simple
idea by the very powerful idea and it
comes up all the time in analysis and
geometry and it also comes up here so
let's do the actual proof
so let okay so let me let P be a subset
of X be a maximal subset of X such that
the sets little T plus B are disjoint
for all elements little T of a set big t
okay so it's it's like this picture I
pick a subset of X so that if I send her
boss around these T's then these
translates a piece are disjoint then
you're putting a maximal such set so due
to the destroying this we find that the
product of the sizes of T and B equals
to the size of the sum because there's
no overlaps but T plus B past size at
most X plus B because T is a subset of X
but I also from the assumption we knew
that X is size of X plus B is upper
bounded by the size of B times K so in
particular we get that the size of T is
at most
okay so in other words over here the
number of blue balls you can control by
simply the volume now since T is since T
is maximal
we have that for every little X there
exists some little key such that the
translator be given by X intersects one
of my children translates yes if this
were not true then I could have put in
an extra translate of P so in other
words there exists two elements B and B
prime such that T plus B equals to X
plus B Prime and hence X licen little T
plus B minus plus B minus B which
implies that the set X lies in T plus B
minus B okay so that's the Ruza covering
lemma so it's an execution of this idea
I mentioned earlier that a maximal
packing implies a good covering any
questions all right so now we have this
tool we can prove an easier version of
fragments theorem where instead of
working the integers we're gonna work in
a finite field model so usually it's
good to start with finite field models
things a bit cleaner and in this case
actually only requires a subset of the
tools that we'll need for the full
theorem so instead of working finite
field model we're gonna work in
something just slightly more general but
it's the same proof so we're going to be
working in a group of bounded exponent
hi mr. in groups of 10 the exponent and
the word exponent in group theory means
the following so the exponent of an
abelian group is the smallest positive
integer if it exists okay so the
smallest positive integer are so that
our x equals to 0 for all X in the group
so for example if you are working in FP
to the end then the exponent is P which
every element has if you add to yourself
our x then destroys the van is just the
element the name of the exponent the
word exponent comes from I mean you can
define the same thing for non abelian
groups in which case you should write
this expression using the exponent
instead of addition multiplication so
that's why it's called exponents so the
names stuck even though we're still
working the additive setting we're going
to write this okay so the angle brackets
to mean the subgroup generated by the
subset a a is a subset of the group
elements and so the exponent a group
then is equal to the maximum number of
so if you pick a good element look at
how many group elements does it generate
okay so it's equal to the max all right
so I mean the example you can have in
mind is f2 to the M which has exponent
two so in general we're going to be
looking at a special case in a group
with bounded exponent and freeman's
theorem in this case is due to Gousha
who showed that if you have a finite
subset
in a billion group with exponent are so
finite exponent if a has doubling
constant at most K then okay so what do
we want to say we want to say just like
in Freeman's term that if a has found a
doubling then it is a large portion of
some structured set and your structure
set means subgroup well if you're going
to be looking at subgroups that contain
a you might as well look at the subgroup
generated by a so the claim then this
that the subgroup generated by a is only
a constant factor bigger than a itself
okay so let me say it again if you have
a set a in a group of bounded exponent
and a has bounded doubling then
conclusion is that a is a large
proportion of some subgroup conversely
you know we saw last time if you take a
subgroup it has doubling constant one so
if you take a positive proportional
constant proportion of the subgroup it
also has bounded doubling and this
statement is some sense certain some
sense a converse of that observation
this bound here is not optimal I'll make
some comments about what we know about
these bounds but for now just view this
number as a constant any questions about
the statement all right so let's prove
this rucious theorem giving you
fragments theorem in groups with bounded
exponent so we can be applying the tools
we've seen so far
starting with plain Ikaruga
okay so by applying the kirusha
inequality we find that okay so and you
know I'm gonna write down some
expression you might wonder why this
expression because we're going to apply
covering lemma in a second so this set
by plane the kirusha it's size is
bounded because ii also be written as 3a
minus a so it's size is bounded by K to
the fourth times size of a so pretty
huge oh it's a very nice tool to have it
basically tells you if you have found
the doubling then oh the other iterated
sums are essentially controlling size
and that were using that here okay so
now we're in the setting where we can
apply the Rouge are covering lemma so by
covering lemma we're going to apply the
covering lemma so using the notation
earlier with X equal to 2a minus a and B
equal to a by covering them up there
exists some key being a subset of to a
minus a with P not too large because of
our earlier estimate and such that 2a
minus a is contained in P plus a minus a
right so it's easy to get lost in the
details but what's happening here is
that I start with a and I'm looking at
how big these iterated growing some sets
can be and if I keep on doing this
operation like if I just apply plan the
kirusha
I can't really control the iterated sums
by an absolute down this bound will keep
growing if I take bigger iterations but
rules are covering lemma gives me
another way
to control the bounded iterations access
their some bounded set T such that this
iterator some is nicely controlled so
let me iterate this bound even further
we're going to iterate the containment
by adding a to both sides a to both
sides and we obtained that 3a minus a is
contained in T plus to a minus a but now
to a - a was containing T plus a minus a
so you got two T plus a minus a okay so
now we've we've gained quite a bit
because we can make this iteration go up
but not at the cost of iterating a but
at the cost of iterating T but T is a
bounded side bounded size T is bounded
size so T will have very nice control
will be able to very nicely control the
iterations of T if we keep going so we
find that for all integer and positive
integer n n plus 1 a minus a is
contained in NT plus a minus a but for
every integer n the iterated sums of T
are contained in the subgroup generated
by T so therefore if we take n to be as
largest you won't see that the left-hand
side eventually becomes the subgroup
generated by a and the right-hand side
does not depend on and
so you have this containment over here
we would like to estimate how large the
subgroup generated by a s so you look at
that formula and we see that the size of
the subgroup generated by T and here's
where we're going to use the fact that
the assumption that the group has
bounded exponent or so think F 2 to the
N if you will I mean F 2 to the N if I
give you a set T what's the space
subspace spanned by T what's the maximum
possible size it's a most 2 raised to
the number so in general you also have
that the subgroup generated by T has
size at most R raised to the size of T
in a group of exponent or which we can
control because T has bounded size and
the second term a minus a we also know
how to control that by plan Ikaruga
therefore okay so putting these two
together we see that the size up here is
at most R to the K to the four times K
squared size of a which is the bound
that we kind any questions so the trick
here is to only use clinical Russa
somehow a bounded number of times if you
use it too many times you can't I mean
this bound blows up but you use it only
a small number of times and then you use
the ruler covering them up so that you
get this bounded set T that I can
iterate let me make some comments about
the bounds that come out of this proof
so you get this very clean bound just
following this proof but what about
examples so what kinds of examples can
you think of where you have a set of
bounded doubling but the said generated
a group generated by that set is
potentially large so even in f2 f2 to
the M so if a is an independent set so
basis or subset of a basis for instance
then okay so independence that so all
the pairwise sums are distinct so K is
about size of eight over two that's the
doubling constant whereas the group
generated by a has size two to the size
of a which is around two to the 2k
times the size of a okay so you see that
you do need some exponential blow-up
from k2 this constant over here and
turns out that's more or less correct so
so the optimal constant for F 2 to the N
is now known very precisely I said if
you give me a real value of K then I can
tell you you know there are some recent
results that tells you exactly what is
the optimal constant you can put in
front of the age so very precisely
asymptotically it looks like 2 to the 2
K divided by K so that's that's what it
looks like so this example is basically
correct for general are we expect a
similar phenomenon so roots are
conjectured that in the hypothesis of
the theorem the constant you can take is
only exponential in K so R to the some
constant C times K and it has been
verified for some values of our but not
in general so know for some are for
example primes
okay any questions all right so this is
a good milestone so we've developed some
tools and we were able to prove a easier
version of Fryman serum in a group of
bounded exponent and you can ask
yourself you know does this proof work
in two integers and well literally not
because if you look at this proof you
know this set here is infinite unlike
you know finite field setting in the
integers well that's not very good
so the strategy of Freeman's theorem the
proof of prime minster is to start with
the integers and then try to not work in
the integers but try to work in a
smaller group even though you start you
know may be very spread out set of
integers I want to work in a much
smaller group so that I can control
things within that group and this is an
idea called modeling a big set and want
to model it by something in a small
group okay we're gonna see this idea but
to understand what does it mean to have
a good model for set in a sense of
additive combinatorics I need to
introduce the notion of Fryman
homomorphisms
[Applause]
so one of the central philosophies
across mathematics is that if you want
to study objects you should try to
understand maps between objects and
understand properties that preserves map
never preserved under those maps so if
you want to study groups I don't really
care how you label your group elements
by one two three or ABC what I care
about is the relationships and those are
the data that I care about and then of
course then you have concepts like group
homomorphisms group isomorphisms that
preserve all the relevant data similarly
any other area you know in geometry you
have manifolds you understand not
specifically how they embed into space
but what are the intrinsic properties so
we would like to understand what are the
intrinsic properties of a subset of an
abelian group that we care about for the
purpose of additive combinatorics and
specifically for fragments theorem and
what we care about is what kinds of
additive relationships are preserved and
Fryman homomorphisms capture that notion
so roughly speaking we would like to
understand maps between sets impossibly
different groups in possibly different
abelian groups that preserve only
partially preserved additive structure
okay so here's a definition suppose we
have a and B and there are subsets
between subsets in possibly different
abelian groups could be the same but
possibly different and everything's
written under addition as usual so we
say that a map fee from A to B is a
Fryman as homomorphism so that's the
term Fryman s homomorphism sometimes
also the whole frame and homomorphism of
order s so that's equivalently I can
call it that as well if the following
holds if we have the equation P of a
plus da da da plus fee of a sub s equal
to fee of a prime 1 plus da da da plus
fee of a prime s
whenever a to AAS a prime to a s prime
to a1 prime to s prime satisfy the
equation a 1 plus peridot plus is equal
to a 1 prime plus da da
plus a s Prime ok so that's the
definition of a Fryman s homomorphism it
should remind you of the definition of a
group homomorphism which completely
preserves additive structure let's say
between abelian groups and for Fryman
homomorphisms and only asking to
partially preserve additive structure so
if so the point here is that if I only
care about let's say pairwise sums if
that's the only data I care about then
Fryman s homomorphisms preserve that
data
to give you some okay one more thing if
a so if be from 8p yes furthermore
rejection and both fee and fee inverse
are Fryman ask homomorphisms then we say
that p is a Fryman s isomorphism okay so
it's not enough just to be a by ejection
but it's a projection and both the
forward and the inverse maps are Fryman
s I so fine Fryman homomorphisms so
these are the definitions we're gonna
use let me give you some examples so
every group homomorphism is a Fryman
homomorphism of every water so group
homomorphism is preserve all additive
structure and Fryman homomorphisms only
partially preserve additive structure a
composition so if p1 and p2 are Fryman s
homomorphisms then c1 composed with v2
is a Fryman as homomorphism okay so
compositions preserve this property and
likewise if you have instead of
homomorphisms if you have isomorphisms
then that's also true as well that's
what these are straightforward things to
check
so a concrete example that shows you a
difference between
group no more isms and from isomorphic
priming homomorphisms is supposed to
take an arbitrary map fee from a set
that has no additive structure okay so
it's a four element set has no additive
structure and I map it to the integers
claim that this is a Fryman to
homomorphism so you can check so you can
you know whenever this is satisfied but
that's never non trivially satisfied so
an arbitrary map here is a fragment you
homomorphism and if furthermore so if
you have let's say I buy action between
two sets both having no additive
structure if it's a projection then it's
a Fryman isomorphism of here order -
okay let me give you a few more examples
so in you know when you look at
homomorphisms between finite groups so
you know that if you have a homomorphism
and it's also a bisection then it's an
isomorphism but that's not true for this
notion of homomorphisms right so the
natural embedding okay so the natural
embedding that sends the boolean cube to
the boolean cuba mute as Zima
2 to the N so yes ok so what's happening
here this is a part of a group
homomorphism right so if you look at Z
to the N and I do mod 2 when I restrict
this boolean cube that's the group
homomorphism if I view this as a subset
of a bigger group so it is a Fryman
homomorphism of a be water and it's by
active but it is not at Fryman to
isomorphism because you have additive
relations here that are not present over
here so if you read the definition the
inverse map there are some additive
relations here that are not preserved if
you pull back so here's another example
that will be more relevant to our
subsequent discussion the mod n map
so the mod nmap which sends Z to Z mod n
so this is a group homomorphism so hence
it's a Fryman homomorphism four of every
order but it's not okay so if you look
at this map and even if I restrict to
here okay so it's not an ISIL Fryman
isomorphism just like earlier however so
if okay so let me go back to Z so if a
is a subset of integers with diameter
less than n over s then this map more
than maps a Fryman s isomorphic T onto
its image so even though mod n
restricted to 1 to n is not a Fryman
isomorphism of order 2 if I restrict to
a subset that's let say contained in
some small interval then all the
additive structures are preserved ok so
let me show you why so this is this is
not too hard once you get your head
around the definition so indeed
if you have group elements a 1/2 a s a
prime 1/2 a prime s and if they satisfy
the equation they satisfy this equation
so we're trying to verify that it is a
Fryman s isomorphism namely the inverse
of this map is a Fryman s homomorphism
so if they satisfy this equation so this
is satisfying this interpretation in the
image in Z mod n then note that the
left-hand side so all of these aids are
contained in a small interval because
the diameter the set is less than n over
s so if you look at how big a 1 minus a
1 prime can be which most what's less
than and whereas in size so the
left-hand side in absolute now viewed as
an integer so the left-hand side is less
than and in absolute value since the
diameter of a is less than n over s so
you have some number here which is
strictly less than any absolute value
and this 0 mod n so it must be actually
equal to 0 as a number as an integer so
this verifies that the additive
relations up to sy sums are preserved
under the mod n map if you restrict to a
small interval
any questions so far
so in additive combinatorics we are
trying to understand you know properties
specific additive properties and the
notion of Fryman homomorphisms and
Fryman isomorphism capture in what
specific properties we need to study and
what are the maps that preserve those
properties and the next thing we will do
is to understand this model lemma the
modelling lemma that helps us if you
start with a set a with small doubling
initially a may be very much spread out
in the integers I may have very large
elements very small elements per spread
out but if a has small doubling
properties then I can model a by a small
inside a small group such that all the
relevant data namely relative to this
Fryman homomorphisms are preserved under
this model okay so let's move on to the
modeling lemma the main message of the
modeling lemma is that if a has small
doubling then a can be modeled and here
I mean it's being Fryman isomorphic to a
subset a small coupe so first as a
warm-up let's work in the finite field
model just to see what such a result
looks like and it contains most of the
ideas but it's much more clear it's much
cleaner than in the integers in the
finite field model
specifically f2 to the end okay so what
do we want to say suppose you have a a
subset of f2 to the M and suppose that M
is some number such that 2 to the M yes
least as large as si - si okay so
remember from clinical Russa you know
that if a plus a is small then this
iterated sum is small so suppose we have
these parameters and sets the conclusion
is that a is Fryman s isomorphic to some
subset of F 2 raise to M so initially a
is in a potentially very large vector
space or it could be all over the place
and what we are trying to say here is
that if a has small W so if a small
toppling then I plan Ikaruga si - si has
size not too much bigger than a yourself
only a pound at times size of a itself
so I can take an M so that the size of
the scoop there's only a constant factor
large larger than the size of a itself
so we're in a pretty small group so we
are able to model a even though
initially it sits inside a pretty large
and being group by some subset in a
pretty small group all right so let's
see how to prove this modeling lemma so
the final few setting is much easier to
image and start to hard to deal with
because we can look at linear maps so
the following are equivalent for linear
maps of ism's sophie is a Fryman s
isomorphism when restricted to a so here
fee I'm going to let it be a linear map
from f2 to the N to f2 to the M the
following following are equivalent so we
were like fee to be a Fryman s
isomorphism when restricted to a so
frightened because this means that or a
restricted a and I restrict to its image
Fryman isomorphic li maps onto the image
okay so what does that mean so well if
as it sophie is already a homomorphism
so it's automatically a Fryman s
homomorphism for it to be an S
isomorphism it just means that there are
no additional linear relations in the
image that were not present earlier
which means that P is injective si so
let's just think about the definition
and in the definition use if you know
additionally that fee is homomorphism
everything is much cleaner it is also
equivalent to the fee of X
is nonzero for every nonzero element
acts of si - si so so this is a very
clean characterization of what it means
to be in Fryman s isomorphism when you
are in an abelian group and you have
linear maps homomorphisms so if we start
by taking si to be a uniformly random
linear map so particular so for example
you find you pick a basis and you send
each basis element to a uniformly random
element then we find that if QM is at
least as a - si then let me call these
properties one two three so then the
probability that three is satisfied is
positive because each element of si - si
well I can also ignore zero so each
nonzero element of si - si is violates
this property with probability exactly 2
to the minus n everything's uniform
so if there are 4 few elements and space
is large enough then the third bullet is
satisfied with positive probability so
you get Fryman s isomorphism any
questions listed to get this model in
this case in the finite field setting
it's not so hard so you kind of project
the whole set even though initially you
might have very be very spread out into
a lot of dimensions you projected down
to a small dimensional subspace randomly
and that works so that with high
probability preserves all the additive
structures that you want provided that
you have small table now let's look at
what happens in Z so in Z things are a
bit more involved but the ideas actually
a lot of the ideas come from this proof
as well so rucious multi-link memo tells
us that if you have a set of integers
always a finite set and integers s and n
are such that n is at least si - si then
ok so it turns out you might not be able
to model the whole set a but it will be
good enough for us to model a large
fraction but then there exists a a prime
a prime subset of a with a prime being
at least a mass fraction of the original
set and a prime is Fryman s isomorphic
to a subset of Zemo
so same message as before with extra you
know so with an extra ingredient that we
did not see before but the point is that
if you have a set a with controlled
doubling then well now you can take a
large fraction of a that is Fryman
isomorphic to a subset of a small group
this is small because we only need n to
exceed si - si which only constant
factor more than a size of a sir x
squared around - separating some integer
thank you so in our application s will
be a constant s will be 8 so think of SS
or some specific constant any questions
so let's prove this this modelling memo
we want to try to do some kind of random
map but it's not clear how to start
doing a random map if you just start in
the integers so what we want to do is
first place ourself in some group where
we can consider random autumn or physics
so we start by perhaps we're very
wasteful choosing a prime Q bigger than
the maximum possible si - si ok so just
choose a large enough prime I don't care
how large you pick you can be very very
large to pick a prime and now I work
inside Z mod Q I notice that if make you
large enough then a sits inside Z mod Q
Fryman isomorphic Li s isomorphic Li so
just
take you large enough so that you don't
have to worry about any issues so yeah
so the mark you map from A to Z mod Q
right so it's Fryman isomorphic friendly
s isomorphic on to its image so let's
now consider a sequence of maps and
we're going to notice sequence so we
start with Z that's where a originally
sets and maps to Z mod Q so that was the
first map that we saw and now we want to
do a random automorphism kind of like
the random map earlier but in Z mod Q
there are lots of nice random of
morphisms namely multiplication by some
nonzero element and finally we can
consider the representative map where
every element of Z mod Q I can associate
to it a positive integer from 1 to Q
which is greased with it so the final
step is not a group homomorphism so so
we need be more careful so let me denote
by P this entire map right so from the
beginning to the end this composition
out to node by C and lambda here some
element between 1 and Q minus 1 now
remember what we said earlier that this
map this final map here might not be a
Fryman homomorphism because there are
some additive relations here that are
not preserved over here but if I
restrict myself to a small interval then
it is a Fryman home or ism if you
restrict to that interval if you
restrict yourself to an interval you
cannot have extra relations over here
because they cannot
of all small enough you can't wrap
around so let's consider restrictions to
small intervals but I start with a over
here so I want to restrict myself to
some interval so that I still have lots
of a in that restriction and you can do
this by pigeonhole
so by pigeonhole for every lambda there
exists some interval go to Noba and i
sub lambda inside queue okay so the
length of this interval will be at most
Q over s such that if I look at the
restriction of this interval I pull it
all the way back to the beginning then I
still get lots of elements of a so a sub
lambda in the elements of a whose map
gets sent to this interval has at least
a over s elements so for instance you
can chop up Q into s0 intervals so one
of them will have lots of elements that
came from a
okay this is why in the end we only get
a large subset of da
we're going to forget about everything
else and focus our attention on the set
here
thus by our earlier discussion having to
deal with the final map being the Fryman
s homomorphism when you're working
inside a short interval we see that fee
if you restrict to this a sub lambda is
a Fryman as homomorphism each step is a
Fryman homomorphism because it's a group
homomorphism and the final step in this
direction in the restriction is also a
Fryman homomorphism from an s
homomorphism because what we said about
working inside short intervals okay so
so this part is it's very good all right
so now let me consider one more
competition so at the end of the day we
would like to model this 8 lambda inside
some small circular group so far we
don't have small circular groups yet but
I'm going to manufacture a small
circular group so we're going to
consider an app where first you take
that feet all the way until the end and
now you take a mod M map so if I don't
write anything if it goes to Z mod and
it means the mod n map so so let me
consider feet Asylum can assign which is
the composition of these two maps
[Applause]
all right so we would like to say that
you can choose this lambda so that this
a sub lambda gets mapped Fryman s
isomorphic li until to the end so far
everything looks pretty good so you have
Fryman s homomorphism and you have a
group homomorphism so you have a so the
whole thing is a Fryman s homomorphism
so see the sign is restricted to a sub
lambda is a Fryman s morphism but now
the thing that we really want to check
is if there are some relationships that
are present at the end in Z mod M that
were not present earlier
so we need to check that claim that if
sigh there's no map a sub lambda Fryman
isomorphic Li then something has to have
gone wrong right so if it does not map a
lambda
Fryman isomorphic Yeong to its image
then so what could have gone wrong claim
that there must be some D which depends
on lambda in si - si and D is not zero
such that V of T is 0 mod M okay so what
prove this you know like before it's
very similar idea to what's happening
earlier the idea is that if you have we
want to show that there are no
additional additive relations in the
image so we would like to so if it's
none from isomorphism then there has to
be some accidental collisions and that
accident no collision has to be
witnessed by some D okay so this
requires some checking
so suppose
indeed suppose the hypothesis suppose
that we suppose that the site does not
map aesop lambda Prime and s isomorphic
Li on to its image then there exists a 1
to a s a 1 prime to a s Prime in a
lambda such that they do not have added
a relation but their images do have this
additive relation now their images all
the way in Kotian having the abject
relation means that fee has this
additive relation mod M ok so how can
this be recall that since the image so
all of these elements lie inside some
short interval the interval has length
less than 2 minus s ok so we saw this
argument very similar argument earlier
in before the break because everything
lies in the short interval we see that
this difference between the left and
right hand sides
this difference is strictly less than Q
now by switching the ace and a primes if
necessary we may assume that this
difference is non negative
okay so otherwise it's just a labeling
issue otherwise I relabeled them so then
this here so what's inside to this
expression okay so let me hold this
expression inside the absolute value
call it start so so then so star some
number between 0 and strictly so at
least 0 and strictly less than Q
so if we set D to be the okay so DT this
expressions are sum up so the difference
between these two sums on one hand the
sting here sorry
that's what I want to say suppose you
don't have an alkie so if you if you are
not mapping from an isomorphic leon to
the image then i can exhibit some
witness for that now isomorphism meaning
a bunch of elements that do not have
additive relations in the domain but i
do have a little relation in the image
so if we set this D then it's some
element of si - si and it's nonzero
because we assume that D is non zero and
okay so then what can we say about fee
of D so fee FD I claim must be this
expression over here the difference of
the corresponding sums and the image
because the two sides are congruent mod
Q two sides are congruent mod Q and
furthermore they are in the interval
from 0 to strictly less than
so this is it's a slightly subtle
argument but the ideas are over simple
just have to keep track of the
relationships between what's happening
in domain what's happening in the image
somehow I think they find a few cases
quite illustrative of it there you know
what goes wrong is similar to what goes
wrong here except here you have to keep
track up in more things okay so
consequently thus fee of T is congruent
to 0 mod M which is what we're looking
for so that proves the claim any
questions yep okay so so this part so we
said T to be this expression I claim
this equality okay so why is the true
first the left-hand side and the
right-hand side they they are congruent
to each other
mount Q okay so why is that
sorry
exactly if you look at feet where was it
there you see that everything preserves
even though the very last step is not a
group homomorphism mark you is preserved
right so even though the last step is
not cool homo vision it's it is so
marquee so if you're looking at mark you
everything is cool homomorphism so so
here we're good both are in this
interval the right hand side is in the
interval because of our sumption about
short everything living inside a short
interval and the left hand side is by
definition because the image of feet
okay it's in that interval so especially
if given that B is not equal to zero
okay okay yeah so it's it's not hard but
it's a bit confusing so think about it
alright
so we're almost done so we're almost on
improving the Fryman so the Arusha
modeling lemma in in Z mod n so let me
finish off the proof
so for each so for each nonzero D in
this iterated some set we basically we
would like to pick a lambda so that that
map up there does what we want to do if
it doesn't do what we want to do then
it's witnessed by some D like this those
are in the path lambda so that if there
exists a D then this lambda is bad
so for each D that potentially witnessed
some bad lambda B number path lambda
okay so I such that P Q V of P is
congruent to 0 so here we're no longer
even thinking about the group for
morphisms anymore order or the Fryman
homomorphisms just the question if I
give you a nonzero integer
how many lambdas are there so that P of
P is divisible by M remember that we
picked Q large enough so that initially
you know you are sitting very much
inside this everything's everything's
really between 0 and Q so this dot
lambda up there acts uniformly so the
number of such paths lambdas is exactly
the number of elements in this interval
that are divisible
by EM so everything's more or less a by
gesture if you restrict to the right
places and the number of such elements
it's at most Q minus 1 over m so
therefore the total number of paths
lambdas is at most for each element D of
si - si a nonzero element we have a most
Q minus 1 over m bad lambdas so the
total number of paths lambdas is
strictly less than Q minus 1 so there
exists some lambda such that sy when
restricted to a sub lambda maps homo
Fryman s isomorphic tree
[Applause]
somehow I think it's really the same
kind of professor why in the finite fuel
case except you have this extra wrinkle
about restricting to short diameter
intervals to short intervals but the
idea is very similar okay so that's the
Fryman model lemma in the integers and
let me summarize what we know so far
and so that they give you a sense of
where we're going in the proof of
Freeman's theorem so what we know so far
is that if you have a subset of integers
a finite subset such that a plus a this
size eight times okay and most doubling
constant at most K then there exists
some prime and at most 2k to the 16th
times the size of a and some subset a
prime of a such that a prime is prime
and a isomorphic to a subset of Z mod n
Z follows from two things we've seen so
far because by the political lúcia
inequality an a minus a a is and most K
to the 16 times a and now we can choose
a prime and between K to the 16 and 2
times K turn 16 and apply the modeling
lemma
okay so that's where we are at so you
start with a set of integers with small
doubling then we can conclude that by
keeping a large fraction of a keeping I
forgot to okay so very important so
there exists some eight which is a large
fraction so keeping a large fraction of
a I can model this large subset of a by
some subset of a cyclic group where the
size of the cyclic group is only a
constant times more than a size of a so
now we are going to work inside a cyclic
group and working with a set inside a
cyclic group that's a constant size a
constant fraction of the cyclic group
question is why eight okay so that will
come up later okay so basically you need
to choose some number so that you want
to preserve the structure of G a piece
so that will come up later and now we're
inside a cyclic group and you have a
constant fraction of a cyclic group
where have we seen this before okay so
when we proved Roth's theorem I so that
was the setting so you're in a sick loop
you have a constant fraction the
circular group and you can do Fourier
analysis so initially you cannot do
Fourier analysis in just starting with
Fryman Sturm because the set may be very
very spread out but now you are a large
fraction of a cyclic group so we're
going to do Fourier analysis next time
to show that such a set must contain
lots of structure just from the fact
that it is large so that will be the
next set good happy Thanksgiving